Assertions in the code are there to stay.
We use them for catching errors, which we can also use during testing, but they also serve
as documentation tool for programmers because they show what the assumptions
of individual methods are and they show what the individual method is supposed to produce.
Now let's apply assertions to another program, an old favorite of ours--
our buggy HTML stripper from the first unit.
So here again we have the function to remove HTML markup,
which we already know from the first unit.
Here as well, a simple assertion would have sufficed to catch the error, mainly an assertion
that checks for the non-existence of HTML tags in the output.
Such an assertion could be something like this--we simply check whether there is any less than sign
that is the beginning of an HTML tag in the output.
We assume, there's none and if there would be one, then the assertion would immediately fail.
So here comes the quiz.
With this assertion, which input would cause the assertion to raise an exception--
is it foo in bold, is it foo in quotes and bold, is it foo in bold and quotes,
or is it foo in bold and single quotes.
Which of these causes the assertion to fail? Over to you.